For example, and this is a true story,
my entire family uses an application
that has geo-fencing in it.
And we've specified particular
environments to be geo-fenced,
such as our home,
our place of work, and our schools.
Now, whenever one of us enters
of leaves on of these areas,
a sound will play on
everybody else's phone.
So, for example, when I get home from
work a particular sound will play.
My dog has gotten to associate that
sound with one of us coming home and
he gets really excited as dogs do.
So if I'm feeling
particularly mischievous,
I'll play back that sound and
he'll bolt straight to the garage.
I actually have to let him into
the garage and walk him around so
that he can be sure that
somebody hasn't just come home.
He'll be looking for
them to see if he can find them.
Now let's roll up our sleeves and
we'll build a simple geo-fence
app like this one for ourselves.